[Music]
tonight radical 20 20 Democrats are
battling it out in the great state of
Ohio we sent Lawrence Jones to the
Buckeye State to find out what locals
think of the scandal-plagued Democratic
frontrunner Joe 303 300 and his son
Hunter who had a disastrous appearance
this morning
take a look Biden is the front-runner
how do you feel about the hunter Biden
scandal this going on right now that is
so significant in that they're all
talking about Donald and and Ukraine if
they really they really should be
looking and they are at Hunter the whole
idea about Ukraine and hunter and all of
that that is simply politics that's
people digging up crap about everybody
else certainly have questions about all
that's happening with regards to Biden
in the Ukraine and all of that it
doesn't bother me I don't think it's
unique in our country whatsoever I don't
think it's unique in our current
political environment are you concerned
about the hunter Biden said his story
told his story it's like a pay-to-play
type of thing he sold his name you don't
think he would have gotten that job if
he didn't have the last name buddy come
on now Biden says he didn't know about
it well probably not by and said he
didn't know about it oh yeah right
yeah he said he didn't talk to his son
about it also yeah who believes that
nobody apparently democratic voters
they're not happy with their
presidential choices either
according to reports for New York City
Mayor Michael Bloomberg is now
reconsidering a run for president and in
a new poll out of New Hampshire a former
first lady Michelle Obama entered the
race she would be the front-runner with
Biden and Warren trailing behind her and
in three new predictive models by
Moody's Analytics President Trump looks
likely to get the electoral college
votes needed to win re-election in 2020
guess congressman Al Green is right we
better impeach him because we're not
going to beat them joining us now is Fox
News
special Hannity 2020 on the road
correspondent and investigative reporter
Lawrence Jones and Michael Beschloss
president former White House chief of
staff Reince Priebus
and I look at this they don't seem that
they kind of see the reality about the
Biden's Lawrence they're not missing
that yes interesting Sean Westerville
Ohio is one of the diverse groups and a
lot of Independence a lot of former
Democrats they end up going for Trump
the interesting thing that I noticed
here is the people if they were in the
Biden camp they were very defensive of
him but if they were already going for
other Democratic candidates they were
very interested in what was happening
with the honduran Biden thing and if
there was going to be an investigation
of it the one thing that's so concerning
though is although the supporters of the
other candidates see it is an issue none
of the candidates that are on this
debate stage right now are willing to go
after Joe Biden all of us know that it's
Shady
even the other candidates supporters but
none of them going to call him on it
we're looking at a calendar and if
anyone else wants to jump into the
radical pool Reince Priebus they have
deadlines coming up very shortly yeah
good point Sean deadlines so every
candidate has to file paperwork
signatures in every single primary state
and every state's different so starting
on November 8th Alabama starts and so
these Democrats that are talking about
you know the rumors about Bloomberg
Michelle Obama which I doubt all of them
have to start filing all of these
documents in November now this is just
one calendar you can see all the all the
dates filled in every starting in
December every single day leading up to
Christmas is a date practically that
these deadlines come up out so all these
rumors about Bloomberg Michelle Obama
you know I think obviously it's not
going to happen because there's so much
to do Sean there's so much work that go
into this and such upheaval I highly
highly doubt this how do you analyze
what the Democrats are doing our
breaking news Pelosi doesn't have the
votes to have an affair
impeachment inquiry and you got to
believe that those nearly what 40
Democrats that are in districts Donald
Trump won
they can't be too happy with this
ridiculous
no reason impeachment just because we
want to do it we don't like them
impeachment well I think the president's
done a good job as of late in what I
would think he should do more of which
is play the victim a little bit more you
know talk about the big picture talk
about the fact that nothing's going to
get done because of this partisan this
partisan job that the Democrats are
doing you know the other thing is you
know these Democrats have played it all
wrong they've they're going for a
conviction without any evidence and I
think the Republicans should remind the
American people of that and then if look
if Republican I think the White House
said it the other day if if the
Democrats want to take a vote on
impeachment they want to give
Republicans or subpoena power as well
then go ahead and do it and I think that
message although you said it many times
other people have said it many times I
think it has to be repeated over and
over again and let the president play
the victim and talk about the big
picture but what he sees for this
country well Lawrence you were there
you're talking to the Democrats is there
this huge appetite for you know after
three years the do-nothing Democrats
they haven't done a thing is there an
appetite for now another impeachment
push by them among Democrats well I
think well I think the the it's what
where's the appetite period I mean when
I'm traveling all across the country and
I've compared to Trump rallies to just
all of the supporters of the other
candidates and it doesn't even come even
close to that and so I think the reason
why they're asking for a Michelle Obama
or someone like Bloomberg is because
they don't have a lot of support right
now
and Biden is starting to look like a
failure right now with the hundred Biden
stuff you know he admitted it today that
he doesn't believe really he would have
gotten that job if he didn't have the
last night Biden and I think the average
day person is sitting home it's tired of
the corruption the people that are
well-connected and powerful playing by
different rules and I think that's going
to affect them in the next election when
they come out to vote
and they never talked about Ukraine or
China not one time I don't believe that
either alright guys thanks know to see
you